speaking a psychopath my buddy told me
that he had sex with a girl and they had
sex for an hour and I want to talk about
this that is [ __ ] way too long this
is how long you have sex for twenty five
minutes that's it
it's just too long dude it's too long
and that's [ __ ] obvious and if you
are a chick and you're like no I like to
get [ __ ] out no you don't know you
don't dude I love when dudes are like I
could I'll [ __ ] you all night one of my
favorite things to think of is a dude
that's just like I'm gonna [ __ ] you all
night
oh yeah and they're naked and he's about
to go inside Ernie's just like I can't
wait to just [ __ ] you all night and then
he slides inside of Music's oh god it's
over
like oh you get ready for a night of
pleasure oh yeah oh you're looking good
I am gonna take my time that's just so
funny to me dude these [ __ ]
mark ass [ __ ] dude an hour I've never
done that if you're coming to me for a
long sex like that you're gonna be
disappointed man I Berber up front if
your prologue in the Berber dude we came
up with the title already prolong in the
Berber if you're prolonging the Berber
because you think the girl likes to
prolong the Berber or you're like oh
yeah
I'm gonna do it for my ego cuz I could
[ __ ] prolong my Berber forever dude
you're nothing you're a beta dude you're
not in charge I'll tell you that much
you're not in charge there's no way
you're in charge of a tribe 15 minutes
is probably the Golden Hour the golden I
think it's honestly 12 minutes to do the
horizontal mambo is 11 12 minutes and
then you Berber right between that 11 12
minute mark dude if you're going longer
than that what are you doing what's up
with these guys that say they can do it
like three four times in a night you
know how many times I can do it in a
night one then I go to bed
the next morning I wake up and I don't
think about sex for another day you get
one you get one Berber you get 12
minutes every two days that's what you
get the only time you're having sex for
an hour is if you're in a relationship
and you're trying so hard to be
attracted to each other because you
can't Berber I [ __ ] front love my
Berbers man foreplay school do foreplay
as long as you want
it's a masochist thing there's no way
[ __ ] for an hour dude that's not cool
he was like dude we did five six
different positions dude you know how
many positions you do when you do the
horizontal mambo three that's it you do
three positions you go on top she goes
on top and you smash it from behind